the Joe Rogan experience it's crazy that
these moments happen where something
changes in the sport everybody goes oh
let's do that and then a lot of people
start doing it like when Anderson
knocked out Vito or that front kick to
the face yes and everybody's like oh
yeah you go throw that [ __ ] to the face
yeah and then you saw a lot of it you
saw a lot of guys winning that way which
is funny because when you when you take
MMA and you and people need to remember
what it stands for and people for the
longest time like all it's just Restless
to Muay Thai there wasn't you know like
okay we'll do a little bit of boxing you
know and some wrestling they never went
outside that box and then guys like
Stephen Thompson and Machida came in you
know now you see MVP but when you see
these guys they're bringing in a
different dynamic that works for them
now granted they've been doing it their
whole life so you're not gonna be able
to adapt everything that they do you can
still a couple little things from them
you know I don't know if you recall but
I was like the first guy that did that
little I used to use my heel to your
thigh in the clinch against the fence I
did it to Yves Edwards and Yves like
you're such an ass was I couldn't walk
for a week you know cuz I was just
healing him boom boom boom and that
fight was only in the first round yeah
you know and so you have things like
that and then BJ Penn said with Matt
Serra Matt Serra kept punching him right
in the hip bone he's like and I kid you
not Matt and BJ's like for almost two
weeks I couldn't walk they're kind of
like limp because he had [ __ ] up my
hip Wow
so little things make a big difference I
wonder you know when they got rid of
that with from a guard remember those
kicks to the to the kidneys a kidneys
they got rid of those I don't know if
they're back now or not I don't know why
they got rid of those why is it okay to
kick you in the head yeah but it's also
interesting they're like the back of the
head like the back of the head is
illegal but when you roundhouse kick a
guy in the head a lot of times you're
hitting your foot wraps around the back
of the head but it's not illegal well
explain this one to me John Jones has a
loss yeah it's just one of those things
you're just think of yourself this is so
stupid
like John explained it on the podcast
yes does the [ __ ] commissioners
thought that that's how you break bricks
and you can't do that to a person
yep and he basically just said like and
then Laureus Lorenzo had said you know
John he wanted to fight for it and John
goes look let's just leave that alone as
long as we can still do it from the
guard we can still do it from any other
angle if it has a little bit of an angle
this way a little bit of a that's what's
great like when I do my when I do my
podcast with Big John McCarthy there's
things that I don't know like he people
don't realize fighters don't know a lot
about the rules we think we do right but
let me just I don't like to admit
because John you know I don't like to
admit John's right a lot you know like
but there's a lot of things I don't know
about the actual rules and I fought for
years man show up it was fighting for
almost 22 years 23 years also there are
rules of morphed a little yes what do
you think about the new unified rules
like the differences between a downed
opponent now and things you can do that
you couldn't do before but it's not but
they're not are they really finally
unified how it does it Nevada only
except they have a modified version of
it Nevada says you're still a down
opponent if you have one hand down see
for me I feel like look for me I've
always thought that um you should be the
head when you're on the ground yeah like
if I stuff your takedown I should be
only your head right there on all fours
right it doesn't matter especially if
you're not against the cage yeah like
against the cage is the only argument
against it because I can't move he's
stuck that's the only thing that I okay
I grip it then get out of there yeah get
out of there you gotta move it's just
going to create more action more
excitement to the fight that's the one
thing that I liked about Strikeforce
when we were fighting for Strikeforce
was that we didn't allow elbows on the
ground and people like him I the reason
I didn't like him is it just you get at
the time it's sean sherk was the champ
and it was like there wasn't a lot of
movement it was like here and he was so
small as like Bam Bam cut guys and the
fight was stopped there was brisk I'll
bloody and for the actual fan at home
watching the fight not all fans like to
watch blood right you know and so it's
like I want to see a good fight I want
to see guys getting starched and knocked
out right but I want to see a good fight
and so I felt like with when they went
Triforce didn't have elbows you posture
up it creates more space creates more
space let's just guy do his moves as
well as try to get back to the feet you
know or I can back out and try to go be
ground pound there's a lot of things
that you can love it for variation why
would you like it knees on the ground
but not elbows cuz you got cuz I think
they don't like that stop by a cut yeah
I see a lotta cuts if someone's in an or
Sall position your knee and someone in
the face w out let me knock down that be
different than a cut yeah I want to see
guys like I said I want to see I want to
see guys I want see fights end I want to
see them in by a knockout I mean that
would like to use everything yeah I
think knees to the ground but also
elbows I think everything got it yeah I
just think that the especially the knee
to the ground like it shouldn't be okay
that you shoot a takedown and then
you're safe
yeah from in one cuz you're on all fours
that seems crazy to me yeah if you're
not safe it should be that the wrestlers
forced to roll to their back to avoid
the knee to get the [ __ ] away it doesn't
make any sense that you in the center of
the Octagon you wouldn't be able to hold
on and need someone in the head look I'm
a John Fitch one of my best friends okay
um but to watch how he fought Rory
MacDonald like for the fans sake it's
not a fun fight to watch like you grab
the leg and the guys like pushes out lip
legs out and then you chase them on your
knee your hands and knees and you're
fishing for the legs it's just not a fun
fight and also too it makes it makes us
look like doing what the [ __ ] we're
doing right you know it's like I do John
you're way better than that
but at the time you also don't want to
stand with Roy McDonald and that all
changes if you allow knees to the ground
yes it does position the whole exchange
changes yep you're gonna see them start
sprawling knee in the head spawn and
then the other thing as well look if if
the wrestler is a good obviously there
are a lot of good Russell's in the sport
but let's just say the knee misses and
he's able to grab the leg now he can get
the takedown so there's benefits on both
sides if the guy knees and it lands the
guy getting knocked out but if he needs
any misses and I grab the leg and I
Drive into you and take you down now all
I'm on top [ __ ] you up so there's
different ways of looking at it like
when you sprawl you want to get your
hips back get your legs back so when
that happens that you've taken yourself
out of the equation of really engaging
in action yeah once you try to knee me
in the head
now you're engaging back into the action
where I can grab you and take you down
do not on you think there should be a
cage how about that I think that's the
problem
a giant basketball court sized matted
area you remember there was those like
kumite style fights where they had the
mats that were kind of camera can he had
that and then somebody else tried doing
it as well with the world combat league
with Chuck Norris out
right and then the what they call it the
[ __ ] Meyerowitz the guy who started
the UFC tomorrow it's a well yeah what
is it the something Pitts you but you
have a [ __ ] weird name he came up
with some weird name for the pit
hey like way rules like some pit
Fighting Championships it was curved
yeah the whole thing was curved like
that I mean like I don't know cuz like
some guys kind of run a lot as it is
like he's kind of you know like this
boss that oh that's right boss Rutan's
has an interesting thing have you seen
this no world karate combat league or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called what is it
called karate combat yeah just called
karate combat yeah they have like these
karate fights and they fight inside this
area but they have this elevated outside
but this is just stand upright isn't it
I believe so yes yeah but with it's
interesting too because there weren't
pants but they're throwing low kicks and
[ __ ] and they have black belts on like
it's like mmm all right there this is
that this looks like it's somewhere in
LA I don't know their their boss is
still doing commentary on that they're
morphing that changing it they're trying
to evolve it but it's like them streets
actually that one is yeah yeah okay why
not just do more time
[Applause]